- [Narrator] He's a humble,
mildly autistic Christmas tree
farmer.
- You trees sure are gonna make
a whole lot of families
happy this Christmas.
- [Narrator] She's the hotshot
CEO
of a women's protein bar
company from the big city.
- (bleep) you!
I don't (bleep)ing care if it's
Christmas,
you get me that (bleep)ing
shaminey yeast
by (bleep)ing Friday,
or you're (bleep)ing fired!
(bleep)!
- [Narrator] They were polar
opposites.
- Fu-!
- [Narrator] Until fate made
them collide.
- Oh, all my trees!
Christmas is ruined!
- You paid for the trees you
knocked down.
I hereby sentence you to three
days
of helping out on Daniel's farm.
- (bleep) me, can't I just
pay him for the damages?
- Language!
Around here we give out
charming folksy punishments,
young lady.
- Your honor, can I have a candy
cane?
- Sure!
- [Narrator] Things started out
frosty.
- (bleep) I hate this almost
as much as I hate Christmas!
- You hate Christmas?
You're not a Jew are you?
- (bleep) no!
Nothing like that.
It's just I don't wanna talk
about it!
(sobs)
- [Narrator] But fa la
la la love is in the air.
- Last year on Christmas eve,
my family got snowed in,
and I was forced to eat my
husband
and two children to survive.
- We have so much in common!
My son got into a sledding
accident yesterday,
and caught an extremely
rare form of rickets!
He's dead now!
I didn't eat him though,
on account of the rickets.
That's why I love you, Noel.
- I love you too!
And I've decided not to bulldoze
the town!
- I didn't realize that was on
the table.
- In fact, I'm gonna move here,
to start a new family with you
and open a coffee /
flower shop / bookstore.
I'm pregnant too by the way.
- The Christmas miracle!
- Also, I've actually been
an angel this whole time.
- Does that mean I have to
raise the baby by myself?
(bleep) me!
- [Narrator] The Jolliest Holly.
Coming this Sunday to
the Hallmark Channel.
Don't Christ-miss it.